مئات الملايين سيتابعونا مراسم التتويج
عبر العالم وخاصه في دول القمر ولف فيما
بدعه الاف سيكونون حاضرين في هذه الكنيسه
عند اداء الملك تشارلز قسم اليمين لدعم
الكنيسه والحكم بشرف تتقدمهم الملكه
المرافقه كامله وافراد الاسره الملكيه
ولكن في ضوء خلافه الامير هاري وزوجته
ماجن مع القصر الملكي وكشفه المشاكل
العائليه قد يغيب الامير هاري عن تتويج
والده الا اذا تم التوصل الى مصالحه ههه
همم
امين همم
انا
حفله تنصيب الرسمي لجلوس الثالث على العرش
سترافقه تظاهرات الاحتفاليه متنوعه على
مدى ثلاثه ايام من عرض موسيقي باهر لنجوم
يعكسون التنوع العرقي في بريطانيا الى
حفلات الشوارع في مختلف ارجاء البلاد
ومشاهير يساهمنا في انشاء ارث تطوعيه
واحتفالهم باخلاص الملك الطويل للخدمه
العامه
لعل هذا الاحتفالات بتتويج الملك تارز
الثالث المرتقب يعيده فتحه صفحه جديده
للاسره الملكه التي طالتها مزاعم سيئه بعد
عقود من الثبات والعمل المتفاني للملكه
الثانيه لبناء بريطانيا الحديثه لصباح
العربيه مصطفى زارو لندن